もう10月後半かもうすぐもうすぐハロウィンですね
なんかパーティーみたいなグッズをこするとか嫌いですはじめ社長です何かね日本の
ハロウィンってこうなんかただみんなパーティーしたいだけみたいなそしてあわよくば
こんなんか
へいへいみたいな感じな気がするけどあんまり好きじゃな的に皆さん良いよ冬が近づい
てまいりましたが受験生の皆さん神の相場が始まる時期だと思います最終局面ですね
自分の弱点だとを見つけて勉強していくとこだと思うんですけども今回は多分もう今年
は出ないと思いますただでないと思うんで多分2016年バージョンはじめ雪は選ぶ
シャーペ
かっこいいランキングでございます
じゃあ今年まででもねなんやかんや色々出てましたねマイナーチェンジが多かった
色違いとかねグレードが上がったバージョンのシャーペンとか結構いろいろ出たんです
けどもまぁその中で僕がですね独断と偏見で使いやすさも込めてなんですけどもうが
一番前ば見た目ですねかっこいいシャーペンとりあえず田んぼん
準備したのでちょっと本会そちらを紹介していこうと思いますあの勉強のやる気
が出ないと数店で行き詰まった人とかいたらシャーペンを変えてみてください
北高校の時の小遣いが1週間で2000円だったんですけどず県警は毎週射精1本買っ
てたんで何かあればブーブー題材ああああ
こちらクルトガの赤でございまーすまあもう皆さんご存知でしょうくるとがですね
文字が太らないさあずっとシャー芯が尖っているというシャーペンでございます冷凍
カー
関数でこのランキングかなり偏りがあるので多分基本的に赤いシャーペンです値
サーフィン好きなんですよねてくどうぞこの赤バージョンの音くるとかがあんまり見た
ことなかったねすごいか
かっこいいだと思いましたくると姉やっぱデザインが洗練されているのがいいと思い
ます黒と赤です
クルトガエンジンを相変わらずオレンジですこれ短針がこれ0.5なんですけど0.3
になるとこのクルトガエンジンのオレンジが黄色になってた気がします
わかりやすいですねで実際にちょっと変えてみましょうかほら
中の中が来るとか何かちょっと回転するっていうもう皆さん知ってるよね
ちょっと優れた感じでございますとラボがあんまり使わないんですよねくるとがなぜか
というと一緒に沈むんですよ
ほら銀の部分回転する日清この銀の部分と黒の部分の愛車で来いって縮まるの分かり
ますかこれこの子の動きこのを買おう
このブレがあんまね僕は好きじゃないがちょっとね使いづらいですね
全然気にならない人ならいい
と思うんですけどもエヴァ少しだけでもブレるとそれが借家イブれると
どれだけの誤差になるかひょっとしたら却下触れるとでもう一名どれくらいご参加通知
ているかもしれない1m も誤算あるその1メートルでなんぼつの違うかけたかって
想像すると
[音楽]
もったいないなと思いますね何言ってるの俺自分で気もずれない葉っぱ
結構最近紹介しましたこちらスマッシュでございます
相変わらずかっこいいねこの洗練されたデザインちょっと僕てが大きいの持ちづらいん
ですけどもそんなこと気になりませんかっこいいねめちゃくちゃかっこいい服老化って
いう本能的に来る理由が好きなんですよ
基本的に僕全部黒か赤で統一したくなるタイプのでよく見てください
僕のまわりのものだけでスマッシュこの場合召喚したん創刊はせねぇ
スマッシュこの前に紹介したんでちょっと言っていきますまあなんといっても見所はか
キャストですねかけやすさの面では本当にこれの上に出るものはないんじゃねーかと
言うで書きやすいでございますなんでこれボク紹介してから亡くなったらしいんですよ
ね全国のロフトから
アメリカでみたらこれなんか4000円とか7000とかで売ってて
奪いやだって思いました
レアだよ葉っぱねぇこれはねホント皆さんがこれでしまいました
こちゃ
ハイデルガードなんですけども普通のデルガードは違う押されタイプです愛もう俺内で
有名ですこちらデルガードのタイプ lx でございますイーヤーかっこよすぎでしょ
これは河童いすぎでしょこれ好きでしょもうこれ本当に大市場臼杵校友会箱に赤袋田度
ちょっとねこうやっぱ的良いかちょっとの闇の
心が混ざっているというかでどこか後ろめたい気持ちでばっか来るというのはて勝つん
ですけどこれ見てください銀とわかっても主人公からですよのウルトラマンとかの銀十
字基本的にやっぱり銀て分かってねこの中で男だね心をくすぐる何かがあると思うけど
正義的な音だからかジャスティスにこだわりますね僕は結局何か僕の中でねある程度
書きやすさがあればあとは見た目と色だと思っております
失礼しますこの感じ大好きううう買ってこれですよ
高級感がたまんないっすで出るカード金属のグリップですねしっかりここが出る型
システムで書いてても芯が折れなくなっておりますややっぱこの色合いは最高にカッコ
イイですね頭になれたらないこれがちょっと僕の中で今年一番かっこいいなって思った
さあ点でした
悠遊カードで期間
族デッキ作る奴が帰って好きですよこういうこういう高寝方しても折れないんで筆圧
強い人とかぜひおすすめです
たギア資産も文句なしでございます俺が多分今年受験者から絶対これで受験跳んでまし
た見た目では文句なしでこれが一番ではないでしょうか
はいみなさんどうだったでしょうか
完全に私の完全に僕の趣味が出てましたねやっぱりちょっとこのベルガードのプール x
が一つ軍をないってかっこよかったのかなと思いますこちらのにもカッコイイです基本
的にでも使ってるの全部赤黒なんだよ基本的にも赤黒もどれかになってるんでねやっと
赤黒っていいよねこれなんかで他にも色んなカラーバリエーションがあったんでねぜひ
ねああああ終わったアウト
木もあったメッツかっこいいなんとまあ自己満な道だだが俺楽しかったぞ
勉強のやる気が出ないときぜひサーフィン変えてやってみてください
抜ける選手における掛け替えのない武器それがサーペンです
踊るのサーフィン線受験戦争を勝ち抜いてください
何言ってんだ俺
いいえ
me
あっ